hey peter
hey is your internet out i can't i think
my cable's messed up could you go in the
back and get me another one
one of the long ones
yeah right back okay
all right so i've been calling paypal
for
oh my god four months
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i've given them utilities with the
address on it i've given them my social
security number my id a statement from
the company on company letterhead with
signed by everyone i've given them the
statement of information from the
california secretary of state and they
keep asking me for it they keep saying
resubmit yes usually once they realize
that i've submitted all the information
they try to get a hold of compliance or
one of their managers and then they're
unable to do so compliance kicks me back
a letter that says we're unable to
verify the account information because
the business name it's listed as the
business itself which is exactly what
i'm trying to change and i can't just
cancel the account and change it because
there's actual money in there that i
can't pull out what the compliance
department is looking for specifically
is something in your company's
letterhead that says please change the
name to blah blah blah yes so i've
submitted that letterhead twice already
okay let me check another place for that
particular document bam there it is okay
let me just kind of review it for you
okay so now she's gonna call compliance
and she's gonna try to get a hold of
them and hopefully she'll be able to get
a hold of them which means that she'll
be able to change it right now if she's
not able to get a hold of him right now
she's gonna pick up the phone and she's
gonna go i reached out to compliance
and i wasn't able to get a hold of them
so i can't change it right now but what
i'll do is i'll submit that information
for you and then hopefully compliance
will just change it and then
they won't send you a letter or anything
they'll just it'll just be ready to go
in a couple business days and then
tomorrow i'll get an email from
compliance that says we're unable to
change the business name because your
business is listed as the business name
[Music]
[Music]
here are some tips that can help solve
the problem the caps lock on for putting
upper or lower kicks
thanks so much for holding i appreciate
it no problem
okay so if i submit any other
documentation it only res it only
accepts the first page
no it should take all of them is that
i've submitted so much documentation at
this point that the amount of storage
that i'm allowed to
upload is full um
okay great i will do that right now
right
so again uh a new problem presents
itself in this thrilling epic of how we
get this paypal account reinstated
i got an upload link
hey jake
have you seen peter i've been looking
for him uh
yeah i sent him in the back to get a
cable
[Music]
[Music]
peter
42 stop
[Music]
think fast
[Music]
no don't do it please no
don't do it
42 stop
you're supposed to improve the renders
not cancel them
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so i've submitted the final document
hopefully now i'm calling them back
get your first and last name
yeah jake watson uh so i've submitted
all the documentation since april and so
i've done that because apparently it
wasn't in the system
so i resubmitted them
i completely understand and you know if
you have any more problems feel free to
give us a call back or you can always
email them at compliance paintball.com
alrighty
and there you have it will compliance
accept the documentation we'll find out
probably tomorrow morning when i get an
email from them that says they have not
been able to accept the documents
because the business name is listed
as the contact name
it's the end of summer here and with
that
comes the departure
from dear friend peter
so
all joking aside peter it's really been
awesome having you here sending off to
college big moves big times
big learning you're going to be a man
do some learning this also happens to be
our 100th episode a lot of big things
coinciding i hope you guys have really
been enjoying watching this series peter
thank you so much for partaking in all
our crazy story ideas thank you for
having me you'll probably see him in the
next bts just because we have footage
from that that was filmed from before
this episode so
i apologize to the confusion
sorry guys oh i didn't mean
i'm going to school get some sweet
student loans i'm going to be paying
those off for a while living the
american dream i'm going to learn some
film stuff i'm going to take a bunch of
general eds that don't have anything to
do with film
and uh you know i'm going to uh explore
my spirituality in san francisco so uh
yeah
i heard there's gonna be like dim sum
really good what dim sum dim sum them
some what
is that food yes
breakfast food it's really good
cool anyways good luck man i'm sure it's
making a great time and if people want
to like follow you like on instagram or
youtube oh my god i can plug my things
you can plug your things
okay um carmichael's just gonna put a
title right here youtube.com torpedo
films and add peter france on instagram
torpedo film sounds fine no but it's not
spelled like torpedo films it's spelled
like t-o-r-p-e-e-t-o
films
like peter yeah yeah tortilla
yeah
towards sheeto that's what it should
have been yeah so if you guys want to
track peter and his probably lack of
uploading while he's busy at college uh
go check out
his channel
um yeah if you're watching more sick
college vids
check it out dude
i'm expecting some sweet college foods
dude yeah there's going to be so many
san francisco oh it's going to be great
they're going to like like warp
stabilize it and like maybe drive under
the bridge and like see the oh my god so
many times
how about the rest of you guys
yeah yeah well good times and you want a
summer job next summer if you happen to
come back down to la i'll be here
all right sweet cool also make sure to
buy the lg g4
[Music]
i can hear them
traces of who i was who i could have
been
when you're just one in a million what
makes you
unique
special
i need the answer
[Music]
even if it takes seven and a half
million years
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you